libs are not just implicitly embracing
evil they are now very explicitly
promoting it there's a show that's been
making the rounds on social media it's
called has been Hotel it's a cartoon
it's a kids cartoon that you can get on
Amazon Prime right now and it's a
defense of the
[Music]
devil once upon a time there was a
glowing City protected by Golden Gates
known as heaven it was ruled by beings
of pure light angels that worshiped good
and shielded all from Evil Lucifer was
one of these angels He was a dreamer
with Fantastical ideas for all of
creation but he was seen as a
troublemaker by the Elders of Heaven for
they felt his way of thinking was
dangerous to the order of their world so
he watched as the Angels began to expand
the universe in their ways from the dust
of Earth they created Adam and and
Lilith equals as the first of mankind
but despite this ad so a lot of people
are going to wonder what Lilith who's
Lilith I know Adam and Eve Who's Lilith
Lilith is a figure from Jewish folklore
and so Lilith is not a figure from
scripture Lilith is not a figure a
figure from church tradition but Lilith
appears in the Babylonian talmud and
some other Jewish folklore and she's
presented as the first wife of Adam who
refused to submit to Adam um um so
already you're seeing a fairly I mean
you've seen it from the beginning of a
fairly novel take on uh the uh creation
story it goes on but despite this Adam
demanded control and Lilith refused to
submit to his will she fled the garden
drawn in by her Fierce Independence
Lucifer found her and the two rebellious
dreamers fell deeply in love together
they wished to share the magic a free
will with Humanity offering the fruit of
knowledge to Adam's new bride Eve who
gladly accepted but this gift came with
a curse for with this single act of
Disobedience evil finally found its way
into Earth with it a new Realm of
Darkness and sin and the order Heaven
had worked to maintain was shattered as
punishment for their Reckless act Heaven
cast Lucifer and his love into the dark
pit he had created never allowing him to
see the good that came from Humanity
so notice this little word they sneak in
there they say uh Lucifer and his love
but of course Lucifer cannot love anyone
the the traditional understanding of
this is that a love is willing the good
of the other person uh so Fon Sheen
Archbishop Fon Sheen has a a great
distinction between love and sex right
love is about
uh another person and about uh something
outside even outside of you and the
other person and it's about in as much
as it is about a person it's about the
whole person right love
gives sex the way we talk about sex
these days you know hookup culture say
is purely about the self in as much as
it's about another person it's just
about using that other person's body to
gratify the self it's about
instrumentalizing people uh CS Lewis
talks about this in the screw tape
letters
when uh human beings talk about desire
and love it's
about a desire for another person when
the demons talk about desire and love
it's about a desire to use the other
person to devour him it's about always
coming back to the self so there's no
there's no love in the traditional
understanding of Lucifer uh then you
know these these poor hapless little
Rebels you know they're cast and they
don't get to see the good that came out
of their evil but the traditional
understand understanding is and the true
understanding is that the Garden of Eden
was perfect it was totally perfect and
sin and death pervade the world because
man is tempted by Adam and abuses his
free will this this version of Lucifer
is more like a Promethean view of
Lucifer this this view of Lucifer is
that Lucifer actually helps man to
achieve his true potential and so much
more good came out of it though there
was a little bit of evil too you know
life's kind of messy man uh keep going
only the cruel and the wicked ashamed
Lucifer lost his will to dream but
Lilith thrived empowering demonkind with
her voice and her songs and as the
numbers of Hell grew so did its power
okay you you get it here what's funny
from the very beginning they say Lilith
was an equal with Adam but it but Eve is
presented in a way as an equal with Adam
too because Eve is taken from Adam's Rib
so not from his head she's not not above
Adam not from his foot she's not below
Adam is from his rib though they have
different roles and they're
complimentary and so she does submit to
Adam I mean you hear this in Genesis
chapter 3 when they're about to leave
the Garden of Eden and Adam is called on
to love Eve here though you get a
mixture of Satanism and feminism and the
the show is listed as being for mature
audiences but do you really think kids
aren't going to watch that show I mean I
remember when I was a kid South Park was
for mature
audiences kids loved South Park myself
included and though there's some naughty
stuff in South Park relatively to the
rest of the culture it's not so bad
because South Park has a broadly normal
and conservative message this uh not so
much so the the right is up in arms and
everyone's clutching their pearls and
everyone's so shocked can you believe
what the culture has come to that they
would do this I'm not shocked at all
none of this is surprising none of this
is new none of this is original this is
the same thing you see in the first
pages of solinsky's Rules for Radicals
solinsky Rules for Radicals the first
edition has just after the dedication
and
acknowledgement uh to Lucifer that first
Rebel who lost heaven but won himself a
kingdom Solinski is saying I'm modeling
my activism and solinsky's left-wing
activism is is the kind of community
organizing that directly inspired
Hillary Clinton she wrote letters to
solinsky that inspired Barack Obama that
inspired the modern Democrat Party he he
says my leftist
activism is
Satanism is
luciferianism is we our inspiration is
not God our in Inspiration is not our
Lord Jesus Christ Our inspiration is the
devil and Amazon says yeah that what he
said okay yeah that's what we've been
seeing from the beginning leftism from
the beginning has been a rebellion
against
God it leftism the term comes from the
national assembly during the French
Revolution when the people on the right
of the Assembly Hall supported the
church and the king and the people on
the left of the Assembly Hall opposed
the church and the legitimate
Authority it's always been about that
man it goes all the way back to the
Garden of Eden when men say ye shall be
his Gods that's what that's what it goes
back to it goes back to the Tower of
Babel when men tried to become higher
than God and in their pride they were
scattered all around the world and had
they just put themselves at the foot of
of Calvary on their knees they would
have actually been the inheritors of a
far greater uh gift to to become
children of God you know uh Satan here
in this story is just he's motivated out
of Charity and love for mankind Satan is
by definition devoid of Charity it what
really happened is and in the
traditional telling Satan is envious of
man why is he envious of man some say
he's envious of God's power I don't
think maybe that's some of it but he's
also envious of man because man is is is
made lower than the Angels he's fleshy
the the cartoon gets it right in the
beginning they say angels are pure
Spirit yeah that's true and man is made
lower than the Angels but in the
Incarnation when God becomes flesh and
dwells Among
Us that Incarnation elevates man above
the angels and Satan couldn't stand that
which is why he hates man and tempts man
is is constantly trying to devour our
souls including through silly little
cartoons that are now appearing on
Amazon nothing new it's been the story
for all of history man what a great clip
that was now hold
up ring that Bell subscribe to the
Michael NS YouTube channel we'll see you
next time